Các bạn sẽ đăng tình đánh lắc đã tạm định chỉ các tác một cán bộ cạnh xác vào thông
để phục của điều tra vừa tay nạn vào thông nghiệm trọng khiến một học sinh lớn miệng 2 từ vòng
Ngày 2 tháng từ phong cạnh xác vào thông phy xe khu tạm công tyng đánh lắc
đã ra phía định định chỉ công tác đối với một thiếu tác cán bộ trạm cạnh xác vào thông trường bốc
giám phục vụ công tác đều tra làm gió các tình tiếp đến quan đến vụ việc
Theo thông tin bà đầu, khoảng 15 giờ hai mi chính phút ngày 15 tháng từ trên cứu bộ hành mi chính
Bộ án qua sác tụ tên xảy ra của tay nạn vào thông nghiệm trọng
Nạn nhân làm một năm xin mới tạm tuổi
Điều khiến xem máy theo gửi tử của lộ mi bộn đi xảy à kết
khi đến khu bực trên, phương tiện bất ngờ là súng mừng thất nước bên trái thở hướng gì chuyện
Nạn nhân đã từ vòng sau đó
Ê xóc khi vụ việc xảy ra, tông ăn tình nắc lắc đã chỉ đạo phương đình vì phối hợp định tình sắp người dân tình
hình chương đều tra làm gió mình nhân, đông thời tổ chức thông hỏi đổng viên gia đình nạn nhân
Chứ đó, cuộc cành xa gần thông vụ cương ăn đã thông tin bà đầu
Và ra không ăn tình nắc lắc tổ chức hợp báo
Công khai kết quả nữ trà theo quý đi